in the whole attack on titan story, we only get to
see one beast titan in action and it's Zeke Yeager
however in recent manga chapters we actually got
to see different beast titans and their users
so in this video I will show you all beast
titans that appear in the attack on titan.
first on the list is snake beast titan
this beast titan appears in chapter 135
and his holder is unknown its
appearance clearly resembles the
snake it has a very long neck and its
head is covered with green snakeskin.
in season 4 we learned that Tom Ksaver had beast
titan ability before Zeke but we never really
saw his beast titan in action in recent manga
chapters we finally got to see his titan form
Tom's whole body without
a doubt resembles a sheep.
this next one is definitely my favorite with
its long ears and two teeth sticking out
it is obviously resembling a rabbit this
titan appears in chapter 136 and it is
shown very briefly in the background so
there is not much information about him.
some people are arguing that
this titan is actually cart titan
but I don't think that's true in
my opinion this is surely a beast
titan since beast titans always resemble a
certain animal, in this case, an alligator.
Zeke Yeager is by many considered to be the
strongest Marley warrior his beast titan
form is very scary and in combination with his
royal blood, he is most certainly one of the
strongest titan shifters in the series there
are also few more beast titans that I didn't
make drawings of so I'll show you how they look in
the manga panels this one is certainly a monkey,
this one looks like a giant deer, and the
last one is probably some kind of bull.